this is barrow alaska the united states
northernmost city also known as
ukuitavic here a pack of bacon costs 15
us dollars a bag of flour is 20
and a loaf of sliced bread is six
dollars unless you like eating tundra
moss there is no food that can be grown
here the permafrost shifts throughout
the year so all the buildings and
infrastructure have to be raised off the
ground and there are no roads connecting
the town with the rest of the state so
now
the question is what has brought these 5
000 residents to live here why would
there be a town in such a harsh
expensive and inhospitable place why is
alaska
so important for the us in this video we
will tell you everything you need to
know about one of the wealthiest regions
in the country but also one of the ones
with the biggest financial crisis
[Applause]
[Music]
alaska is the biggest state in the us
when it comes to territory in contrast
its population is under 1 million
inhabitants there are almost
no roads and the people are so dependent
on air travel that alaska has one of the
greatest concentrations of pilots per
capita
in the world
[Music]
and let's not get started about the
weather in winter temperatures can dip
below
minus 40 degrees celsius since most
goods have to be imported from far away
many things here are ridiculously
expensive i know it sounds like the last
place you'd want to live
even if you had money to burn alaska
would be the last state you'd want to
live in nevertheless
this state has the fifth highest amount
of millionaires per capita in the entire
united states of the total population
6.75 percent
are technically millionaires
they boost the seventh highest gdp per
capita in the whole country at 73 000
and alaskan citizens get a check from
the state just for living there so if
you're wondering why on earth alaska is
so surprisingly rich there is
one word that answers everything oil yes
dear viewers
dinosaur juice has made alaska the
norway of the us
but as you know during the times of the
coronavirus being oil rich
is not the golden goose it used to be
alaska faces triple hit from coronavirus
due to reliance on oil
fishing tourism reuters as we always say
here on visualpolitik
bald is best and also natural resources
can be a blessing or a curse and
alaska's economy is more than oil
dependent it's oil
addicted so as soon as oil prices plunge
alaskans suffer in fact this is nothing
new since 2014
alaska has been suffering a huge
recession
[Music]
while the rest of the us was riding the
wave of an all-time high economy
alaskans saw their gdp
declining now the coronavirus is making
everything
worse so the question is how much worse
are alaskans really suffering so much
why is alaska so wealthy and why are
they experiencing such a crisis now
is there any way to solve it today we
are going to answer all of those
questions but before we do
let's look at some history
manifest destiny not counting pearl
harbor there was only one battle in
world war
ii that was fought on u.s soil can you
guess where it was yes
it was the battle of atu in alaska the
japanese considered that alaska was so
important from a strategic point of view
that they invaded a part of it for over
a year this already gives you the idea
of how vital this state
is despite seeming to be in the middle
of nowhere
in 1867 alaska was sold to the united
states for about 7.2 million dollars or
two cents per acre it'd been a russian
colony but really
in name only almost no russians lived on
the peninsula and most of the population
were still
inuit just as a side note you might have
heard of inuit people being referred to
as
eskimos but in fact the term eskimo is
very disrespectful
it's kind of an arctic version of the
n-word so we're not going to use it at
the time the us acquired it alaska was
still
untamed as it had been for eons before
but the russians did leave a few things
like their local capital novel
archangelisk which is known as
sitka today the deal seemed questionable
and americans at the time
voiced their concerns about the purchase
of a disconnected and isolated land
but the investment paid off by 1900
people were pouring into the new
territory over the course of
multiple gold rushes
after world war ii many u.s air force
bases were built throughout the state
bringing jobs and more settlers
being so close to russia which after all
sarah palin can see from her house
alaska was the strategic location during
the cold war but
it wasn't until the 1960s that things
really began to pick up for alaska
[Music]
it was in 1959 that it gained statehood
as the 49th state by 1960 at a
population around 222
000 about three times more than 1940
then in 1968
over 100 years after its purchase oil
was discovered and a lot of it however
it would take a while for this discovery
to take effect
you see this oil wasn't found in some
nice green valley in southern alaska oh
no
it was found not far from that little
town of barrow all the way in the arctic
north to tap this oil a gargantuan
pipeline would have to be built across
virgin land about 800 miles or 1
300 kilometers worth of pipeline to be
precise check it out
on this map
it would have been so expensive to get
to that it wasn't even worth it until
1973.
so what happened in 1973 oil-producing
countries of the arab world decided to
use their oil as a political weapon
exactly 1973 was the year of the oil
crisis the oil crisis made the cost of
oil in the u.s
so high that it made building a 1 300
kilometer pipeline to the arctic
and extremely isolated terrain sounded a
good idea it was a titanic undertaking
but hey we are dealing with americans
here and only took them two years to
build one of the world's most extensive
pipelines
this is what brings us back to barrow
[Music]
you see barrow is essentially a
microcosm of the alaskan experience
sure not all of alaska is tundra and ice
but it's the same idea
moving somewhere very isolated and
inhospitable for work
and raw resources the oil field that was
discovered was the largest conventional
oil field discovered in north america
and there's a lot more
where that came from the lands of alaska
are absolutely abundant there's oil but
there's also natural gas precious metals
forestry strategic locations lots of
potential for renewable energy
and seafood
[Music]
yeah let's not forget seafood this
untamed land came with untouched waters
and alaska's seafood industry processed
over 5.7 billion pounds of seafood for
2.6 billion kilos providing a
contribution of over 5.6
billion to the alaskan economy in 2017
to 2018. this local industry employs
almost 60 000 people and supplies half
of the us's fish with opportunities like
these it's no wonder so many people
have moved to alaska which now has a
population of over 740
000 people as we mentioned earlier
alaska has a gdp per capita of around 73
000 which is roughly the same as norway
in fact there are many things that
alaska and norway have in common both
are located in the far
north both have economies based on oil
and fishing nevertheless
there is one significant difference you
could say that alaska is like norway but
without the
black metal and the high taxes well in
fact
there's another difference with the
nordic country while norway's economy
has solid growth
alaska has been suffering a massive
recession in recent years and the future
for this state doesn't look much
brighter why
check this out
[Music]
[Applause]
when oil doesn't pay the bills anymore
it's not all midnight sunshine and
rainbows in alaska the state is feeling
the strain you see alaska faces
quite a lot of issues let's start with
the very nature of the place as we've
mentioned
alaska is a very isolated place from the
rest of the country and this raises the
costs of just about
everything from the diesel that many
locals depend on to the cars and the
medicine you get the idea
then there are many parts so isolated
that they're even cut off from the rest
of alaska the state's own capital
juno can only be reached by boat or
plane because
no roads connect to it in fact lots of
towns and villages are only accessible
by
airplane and if you're lucky by boat for
a few months of the year
it's hard to stress the extremes of
alaska's landscape it totals over 1.7
million square kilometers or
663 000 square miles with just over 740
000 people that means it's twice as big
as texas by area but only has the
population of a city like frankfurt it's
got the population density of half a
person per kilometer and has extreme
weather conditions as you can imagine
it's really hard to ship things build
infrastructure and even govern
the naturally high cost of living is
perhaps one of the reasons the state
actually lacks both a private income tax
and a sales tax so now you can see why
so many millionaires like to live here
right so where does the alaskan
government get their income then
of course the answer is oil and natural
resources
most of the government's income comes
from natural resource royalties
and company income taxes and i know what
you're probably thinking now that
doesn't sound too bad
right i mean alaska has a lot of
resources to pay for
everything right and only those big oil
and mining corporations have to pay
taxes
right that sounds wonderful but not
really take a look at this new story
alaska north slope oil production is
about to be at its lowest fiscal year
level since pipeline startup anchorage
daily news
june 2019. yep it would seem that the
alaskan oil boom has turned to an oil
bust in fact just enough oil is pipes to
keep the whole system from freezing over
a combination of factors has contributed
to this
first of all alaska has quite a lot of
competition for example you have states
like the dakotas and texas which are
going through their own oil booms and
have the added benefit of not having to
extract it pipe and ship it
from the arctic so in other words
alaskan oil barrels are one of the most
expensive to produce in order to profit
from that sweet sweet dinosaur juice
alaska needs the oil market price to be
above 59 us
dollars
[Music]
at the time of making this video the
brent crude price was at 55.89 us
dollars per barrel and
it's been much lower this is why the
2014 crash had such a dramatic effect on
alaska while the rest of the u.s economy
was growing at a rate of 2.5 percent
that year alaska was on the brink of a
massive recession their gdp fell by 1.5
percent that year but in 2015 alaska saw
an 8
recession in a state that's so reliant
on oil the government was in dire
straits
and here's where the biggest difference
with norway comes in do you remember
that we said the state gets most of its
revenue from resource royalties and
company taxes
so when the main businesses which are
all related to oil couldn't make a
profit anymore the state income
tanked by 80 percent in fact the
dependency on oil
is one of the biggest differences
between alaska and norway and the reason
why the norwegian government can survive
an oil crisis well alaska
can't this is what happened during the
2014 oil crash now imagine what could
happen
with the coronavirus crash
[Music]
alaska oil prices likely to hit record
low this week adding to the state's
challenges
adn after this the fact that they are
also running out of oil it's estimated
that alaska has had
60 of its oil reserves depleted that
explains why so many oil companies like
conoco phillips are cutting their costs
in alaska by almost
500 million us dollars just to add a
little icing to the cake
or perhaps that should be to melt it off
alaska
is one of the regions most affected by
climate change the
arctic is warming twice as fast as the
rest of the world ocean acidification is
threatening alaska's fishing calls their
coastline is rapidly eroding
and melting permafrost is destroying
infrastructure
[Music]
so yes all that alaskan wealth might
come to an end and the question now is
what can they do
to avoid a collapse let's take a look
the alaskan dividend alaska is facing
some serious budget problems as well as
an ecological disaster
not only is it starting to run out of
the dino juice it's dependent on but the
prices of its dino juice is also being
out-competed
this explains why the state is reporting
record low production levels
every year now it seems alaska won't
even be able to benefit from the 40
that's left meanwhile the state has an
extremely flimsy tax base and people are
starting to leave the last frontier in
other words if you are mike dunleavy the
current governor of alaska and you're
watching this video all i can say is
sorry dude
alaska budget woes broad debate over oil
wealth fund checks
for decades alaska binged on
infrastructure and community projects
when oil prices were high and cut
spending in closed facilities when they
weren't
this time prices haven't boomed and
after years of drawing down savings and
cutting expenses
state leaders face tough decisions abc
2019.
but wait a minute because not everything
is that terrible
so far in this video we've been
comparing alaska with norway again
both countries rely on oil and fishing
they have high cost of living and
extremely cold weather well there is
another thing they have in common they
both
have a sovereign wealth fund
you see in 1976 during that great alaska
oil boom the state established the
alaska permanent fund
financed by oil and gas revenue which is
managed by a state-owned corporation
now alaska's wealth fund is very
different from norway's whereas norway's
fund is intended primarily to keep
government pensions funded the alaskan
fund was intended to
well no one's actually sure it seems
like they just made the fund because it
sounded like a good idea at the time and
i've come up with reasons
since nevertheless the fact of having a
fund with no clear purpose
has been surprisingly good for alaska
in 1982 the alaskan permanent fund was
changed to go from just saving money for
later to implementing a statewide
permanent fund dividend or pfd
based on the fund's earnings what this
means is that every year since 1982
everyone who lived in alaska got a check
from the state based on its oil revenue
and the fund's investments no funding
scholarships no infrastructure
no pensions nope the state is barely
allowed to touch the money
but each citizen gets a very juicy
dividend for just being in alaska it
doesn't sound too bad right
so the fund takes in resource extraction
revenue invests most of it both in
alaska and even internationally then it
uses those earnings to do things like
inflation-proof the fund but
also to send money out to all alaskans
and you might be wondering so exactly
how much money are we talking about well
the amount was going up and up
until 2008 when alaskans received over
two thousand dollars from the fund
so if you live in alaska you pay almost
no state taxes and then the state
actually pays you and this is needed
given the high cost of living in the
state
in fact it's estimated that the annual
dividend keeps between 15 000 and 25
000 alaskans out of poverty so even if
alaskans are weathering a mammoth crisis
this fund has helped as a buffer to
avoid poverty clusters
so how big is the fund the answer is
pretty big
it's worth over 60 billion dollars yeah
60 billion dollars now the state not
wanting to raise taxes and yet
somehow collect them from isolated
communities began to eye that nice
juicy 60 billion when news like this
started to come out
alaska which depended heavily on
revenues from oil activity dealt with
the sudden fiscal pressures by tapping
into reserve funds and cutting spending
it still faces a budget deficit of 2.5
billion dollars for next year
reuters 2018. alaska has cut its
spending down to the bare bones but it
still needs to cut more
and new oil money isn't coming anytime
soon obviously introducing a new tax
would be
really unpopular so there is one
solution up for debate meddling with the
dividends of the sovereign fund so
basically many legislators want to
channel some percentage of the fund to
the state
it'd be something like the operating
cost that commercial hedge fund would
charge you but in this case
those fees would finance the states of
alaska and you might be wondering would
this be enough to solve alaska's fiscal
crisis
well the answer is yes
[Music]
the state-owned company that manages it
is actually doing a really good job they
have an investment strategy that
includes
high levels of diversification safe bets
and
a lot of careful deliberation today the
fund is valued at around 67 billion
dollars this is a very good figure
considering that at the end of 2016 it
was only worth 55 billion but
would this really solve the state's
budget problems there are many reasons
to believe that
yes it would at the time of making this
video it's estimated that the percent of
market value proposal would completely
wipe out alaska's deficit and maybe even
leave the state a little pocket change
[Music]
nevertheless this is just a band-aid
with this strategy alaska can handle
their fiscal crisis but putting aside
the success story of their wealth fund
alaska's future
seems cloudy clearly an oil-based
economy will no longer work for alaska
when an oil-based economy
is destroying alaska so instead needs to
start thinking about how to diversify
their economy and now the question is
over to you will alaska finally solve
their budget problems with their
sovereign fund will alaska manage to
diversify its economy what kind of
industries could be created in the state
and would you move to alaska for two
thousand dollars a year please leave
your answers in the comments below as
always we really hope you enjoyed this
video don't forget we publish brand new
videos every week so subscribe to
visualpolitik and hit that bell button
so you won't miss any posts i've been
grant
and i'll see you next time and if you
want to learn more about politics and
hear
even more of my lovely voice you can
join us at
reconsider media we have a podcast at
reconsider media.com
podcast see you there